louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Applause]
[Music]
Stephen and the Masters are the Internet
I am prouder prince of you to be
defender of the secrets of Castle mud
club this is poppy hopper scared of deep
platforming fabulous secret powers were
revealed to me the day I held my hand
etched mug and said by the power of mug
club
now this is popper with all the cheese's
and I became Steven the most powerful
conservative on YouTube
[Music]
together we defend Castle mug Club from
the evil forces of censorship
[Music]
Stephen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the whole Cogan or my my
half Italian aunt but also I'm here
because we have Mahmood al Mamoon
Isis communications director to see you
again Steven back by popular demand how
would you show you the softer side
devices as oh yes we really appreciate
it we have Brautigan over there
replacing Joe he's on his honeymoon but
I still don't trust it I have the permit
of the day it's Hudson from the region
of New York we call not New York City
okay Ryan from Goldberg schooled old
school was over eighty five to five I
turn the kid warrior but he's
unbelievably funny I'm hysterical and uh
I'm Joe Rogan show questions I'm looking
forward to having him on question of the
day we're gonna be talking about this
quite a bit do you think college is a
human right and to those of you who went
to college just how necessary or helpful
was it in preparing you for your field
of work and or the real world just
comment below we'll be talking about
that because that's a new talking point
of course that college is a is a human
right I'm sure you've heard this my mood
I have heard this this is a very popular
idea back in my part of the world is
really oh yeah oh not for the ladies I
would imagine no of course not no
leading the news of course we have to
address this is former Vice President
Joe Biden officially knows his run for
president comes from USA Today the core
values of this nation are outstanding in
the world our very democracy everything
that has made America America is at
stake he said in a campaign video
announcing his running he also launched
his campaign unveiling his new official
slogan make America grope again so he
seems pretty yeah should be noted ease
running on the platform of rebuilding
the middle class respecting or at least
earning respect for leadership on the
world stage and pedophilia so it's
better
the funny thing about Biden he's such a
walking punch line I was working with
Pantelis this morning and we were going
back and forth it's like you know
something every joke sells about Biden
something we've heard it before it's
pretty much the case we've got nothing
there's nothing else I'm not familiar
with the American system but everybody
runs for president yes yes that's a good
read on it sir what is it what are we
- now in the Democratic field 617 is 817
all right
as for the current president he recently
met with Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey and
gadget reported this Twitter spokesman
called it a constructive meeting where
they discussed Twitter's commitment to
protecting the health of the public
conversation ahead of twenty20 elections
of course that were detractors actually
our Inside Man at the White House snuck
us this exclusive recording for the
meeting ok so set your ship frankly I
keep hearing that you're censoring
people right with conservative opinions
by a bigots what's what's going on with
that Jack lead so this is a real
challenge and something that were we're
turning up a surprise coming from a guy
who dresses like a post-apocalyptic
lesbian who shops it or we don't we
don't look at the speech or so if we
look at conduct we look at how listen
you band a kid for tweeting that men are
men and frankly women are women okay
saw it as a violent threat and violent
okay then I want to be with all the
other criminals here five Twitter is
that okay Jessica okay there's that okay
I've got many black Fred's frankly the
best blacks are my friends actually
you've heard of Kanye okay Kanye from
the West that's productive as initially
reported no but I like I like this
tradition you know this dates back to
when President Clinton had the CEO of
Geocities
I like that they keep continuing it I've
never rooted for some for Trump to
actually grab someone by the buddy if he
strangled jack I would not be upset he
would just be grabbing jack oh you're
moving in and out of the microphone pick
a spot pick a lane there brother also
regularly this snot otter was named
Pennsylvania's official amphibian comes
from Yahoo the maternal animal is also
known as the lasagna lizard and the mud
devilís comes now with amphibians but
animals the state animals runner-up for
the state's animal honor was the the
[ __ ] platypus to ball sweat Swan and
bear with the regular anal discharge so
they actually went with a good choice
Mahmood how fast can you get Sharia law
to actually take over America you have a
phone Google imaging the the
Pennsylvania's not
a Google image search tit it's just
pictures of Ben Roethlisberger hey this
was interesting as well a high school
student was criminally charged for
ranking girls in his class on Twitter a
man said Mara I want to make sure I get
this right marrows Nasser Sharif he was
charged with telecommunications
harassment and could face disciplined by
the district for his twitter account
quote unquote girls ranked so the main
what's a blow actually in this register
remains anonymous the classmates
strongly suspect 1.4 rated Bulldog
Karen's I think I dated her you guys you
guys mock us for face covering yeah
who's laughing now of course not the
first time that Nasser Sharifi has
gotten into the hot water for misogyny
who can forget his previous
headline-grabbing debacle you probably
member this of infamous hit or quit
adapt hit it hit it oh definitely hit it
hard multiple times quit yes like the
grinder for terrorists pretty good my
biggest issue with this isn't the entire
point of going to high school to grade
your peers yeah like congratulations you
found
I usually that should be taking place at
the hands of a teacher I say that death
penalty is what I say I wasn't paying
attention what did he do I'm in my
opinion does not change I say I'm just
talking about school the role of school
we thought was to grade your peers yeah
oh yeah maybe I don't know I was much
not much for the book learnin no super
big on the death penalty yes on the book
burning in Entertainment News Hollywood
action is like to use apparently safe
words when intimate scenes get to be too
much this comes from the mirror some
even have them written into their
contracts words like pineapple sweet
potato and mayonnaise though it's you
know they stopped using mayonnaise when
Harvey Weinstein confuse it for stage
direction finally there's this video of
the Easter Bunny getting into a street
fight I think we have an initial clip
that was going viral
now it should be initially the viral
video was completely silent but we've
uncovered this exclusive leak that now
includes the original what's going on
just get your ass laid out by the
instrument just here helping the kids
I'm surprised you took any pleasure I'm
not into the Pennsylvania snot otter but
I am all about the floor that a cell
throw then count me in oh my goodness I
think in Florida all rodents are a salt
road I hate Florida I don't know why
anyone likes it I know the New York
people they go there all the time
when you have Gators that are just there
around there like squirrels ceases to be
valuable to me tend to move time to move
but I mean in my peoples defense they go
there do escape New York site taxes
where they then vote for politicians who
raise their tax taxes and the circle I
don't think that's at all an accurate
sequence of events I think they moved to
Florida and died great yeah I was gonna
say thrust me I it beats Kirkuk I have a
little inside baseball here you're not
vented Kirkuk I don't I will see I feel
like Kirkuk is it the same as the state
no it's a it's a it's a city but right
imagine if La Guardia Airport was a
mountain oh so Orlando last week sliders
Carter trivia contest winner is actually
Samuel Bravo at real seminars you
correctly identified Captain America as
a superhero when super gay you will get
a free I don't know t-shirt mind
something Biden hair puppet have no idea
and of course thank you to our sponsor
so he prints Mahmood bill not my moon
bin Salman generous contribution ago she
ate it and it will affect the editorial
process no way whatsoever on the show ok
let's move on to this meet second here
should you go to college this is the
should you go and is it a right there's
the Democrats have been floating this
idea that student bet
debt forgiveness is is now apparently
it's the fulcrum for a lot of these
people and free college overall in case
you doubt me we are going to roll back
student loan debt for about 95 percent
of students who have debt so you deserve
more than to be settled with more and
more debt we've got to induce states to
carry more the burden instead of
continuing to pass it on to students
students are getting squeezed tell you
this Joe loan pandering right now it's
predicated on the idea that college is
necessity and then the left says it
because college is a necessity it's a
right and if it's right then the
government has to provide it for free of
course free tuition at public colleges
and universities that should be a right
of all Americans regardless of the
income of their families there's that
wording it's not a right and how are you
it's not even a necessity there let me
go through a few points there are other
options we always hear about this we
hear about the salaries of people with
college degrees versus people who don't
have college degrees and yeah listen on
its face of course people's college
degrees make on average more but just
like the gender wage gap number you have
to look into a little bit deeper why
don't we talk about trade schools job
placement from people graduating trade
schools nearly a hundred percent the
average college is half that's almost
half that that's half 150 starting
salaries by the way are much higher and
they only contestant arting sell is that
you're saying they only continue to go
up is one screen as opposed to the
Gender Studies major who keeps getting
my coffee wrong by the way we have a
surplus right now over 7 million jobs so
people this is one thing that people
understand when we talk about a market
economy people are paying more if there
are more available jobs and there are
fewer layoffs than there have been in
decades that means that people have to
incentivize you to come and work for
them they tend to pay more hence why
wages have gone up and here's a male's
too how many small business owners
independent contractors have college
degrees thirty percent of business
owners have no college degree whatsoever
okay of the ones who do only 61 percent
believe that a college education was
important for success in today's economy
compared that with 97% of the general
non business owning populace I think
that's important for people to know you
know you know you have some cases like
for what I do now it didn't exist when I
was in college so my degrees can be
useless right and I remember because
when I was first trying to figure out
what I wanted to do
Arthur seabrooke's has a book called
Gross National Happiness and he brought
up how networking is more important than
your did you did you do a lot of
networking there Mamoon no I didn't go
to college I was a graduate of the
school of hard knocks
right which is actually just a room we
have where people hit you right with
rocks yes yes you've heard of it it's
hard yeah commonly known it's a school
of seraya em yes Mahmood the chicken do
more regional research just into where
I've just very focused on my work you
know Aaron Sorkin's talked about this he
says you know I want people running the
government who are hyper the most
brilliant phd's running all honest why
do we look down at business owners who
actually create products services goods
that generate billions of dollars for
the United States economy I mean I
actually have no idea how much what
percentage would be small business
owners versus medium business owners
haven't looked this up why don't we talk
to are they not intellectual because god
forbid their ideas actually have to work
in the real world Thomas always talked
about that's the only place where your
ideas don't actually matter don't have
to work out isn't academia right if
you're a civil if you're an engineer it
better work or somebody's going to die
if you're a business owner it better
work or people are going to lose their
job if you're serious your ideas don't
work you just hide out in the college
and tell kids if they would if Marx
would have been practiced properly by
the way get the notification Bell join
up at mug Club a lot of Kardec I'm slash
smart club because apparently
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
we'll get into more of that later and
subscribe and iTunes for the audio
version here's another point all majors
aren't created equal this would be a
different conversation I would say if
any of the Democratic candidates if any
of them right now we're saying okay
listen we need to create incentives for
advanced science degrees or fields which
requires specialized education obviously
we're not going to be subsidizing four
years of afro lesbian centric studies do
they just know they just want total
stood everything forgiveness free school
they never mention majors different
degrees pay differently good example
engineering finance they pay it they pay
more money so the
gets paid off more quickly are you doing
what you'd studied there Mahmood you
know I wanted to paint and I might get
back to it I'm not sure right but this
all makes sense to me honestly like I
feel like a welding welding a great job
you know yeah people need
well--there's cages market supply it's
man it's the invisible hand that burns
one alive
here's they just all education I got
that blood what you wait till I get to
the section on Hayek just for us not for
the guy who had two glasses of bourbon
beforehand I think he's watching
progress I gonna stop they lump all
education from specialized civil
engineering all the way to feminist
German poetry's equally valid anything
I'll tell you what there's a reason for
that it may not make sense on its
surface and that's because the DNC
Harris Warren Bernie they want you steep
and far left academia people talk about
these numbers a lot but let me just put
them in context liberal college
professors outnumber conservatives
twelve to one thirty nine percent of
colleges have no conservative professors
at all let's let's just round it
basically forty percent of schools have
not a single conservative professor and
the vast a significant portion of
students not even a plurality a majority
say that the climate on college campuses
is hostile to free speech and a lot of
the top tier universities are actually
the worst about this people are going to
Harvard today to take classes and
Beyonce studies and queer fat activism
no but I repeat myself these are real
things and by the way even though
there's a lot of a status attached to
Ivy League schools the actual quality of
education is often pretty crappy since
many of them have now placed a premium
on the leftist indoctrination over
actual education it's only a matter of
time before I think people realize how
dumb some of the students are being
turned out of the apples yeah and again
it's just this anal this idea this
intellectual elitism that if you go to a
trade school if you go to a community
college you somehow must be a dummy or
if you start a business that employs 20
30 40 people
you're an idiot who needs to sit at the
feet of Intelligencia I just don't agree
with it
here's another point you don't have to
go to the most expensive school this is
what everyone thinks that you get into
you don't have to do it Americans are
more strapped by Sting
and 2018 than ever before so why are
students being put in such an awful
situation there's more people more
students are going to school if you
build it they will come and when you
provide them with student loans for all
it's no surprise that you can charge
more for your college education you
don't need this is one thing does that
seem backwards you don't need to take
out as many student loans as you
possibly can you can get a quality
education without spending that much for
some reason kids out there now they
think that they have to apply to highest
tier schools to use that term and then
they have to go to the top when they get
into regardless of cost the truth is
most students have no idea what they
want to do twenty to fifty percent of
them enter schools undecided than most
end up changing their major completely
yeah I know in my case I didn't know
what I wanted to do is fresh out of high
school so I would mean in college and I
only paid a grand a semester as opposed
to twenty mm-hmm I'm also not massive
debt right now right correct same way I
did the same thing I didn't know what I
wanted and look at Brautigan you chewing
at him you too can be broad again right
Mahmood yes I agree plus I think a lot
of the kids you know they have the the
lazy rivers at the college and they have
this the climbing wall and the ice cream
yeah I don't have a very ill conceived
notion of American College and they have
the golden walkways which part is wrong
no no it's mainly just a nanny ice in a
butt chug yeah and let's be honest you
know people say they go to college for
the college experience I did my fair
share of Ivy League drinking at a
community college you don't need to pay
that much no you're really don't you
don't have to go there to drink that
it's glorified outcomes but your folks
don't partake it all in the and the
devil's drink no no they do they do
yogurt pong okay yogurt pong
have you played no oh I doubt it it's
like beer pong but is it yeah with the
open I hear John Stamos's world champion
that terrorist family from Iowa I'm
kidding don't sue us please that was a
terrorist yogurt company that wasn't an
actual terrorist yogurt company let me
be clear dad it was a there was a
terrorist your company no there was not
okay the idea that college as a
necessity I'm trying to move on it's
it's patently false
and it serves as a foundation for the
lie that
College is a human right if your here's
the thing if your dream is to go into a
specialized field that requires advanced
schooling yeah a good university might
be a decent investment but if you don't
know what you want to do or if you're
going to find yourself whatever the hell
that means because you watched Eat Pray
Love once or you're going to variance
you're better off going to a trade
school or Community College until you
get your crap straight here's an idea
I'm gonna say something here that might
be wildly unpopular with our large
largely millennial male audience
diametric opposition to Bernie Warren
Harris the rest if you don't know what
you want to do with your life how about
you go to work and start paying taxes
instead of taking mine there's a novel
idea it's not a right you don't deserve
it you don't need it and I could hurt
you well then Bryan Callen after this
[Music]
what do we have here
it's Castle mug Club and it's mine not
so fast evil YouTube overlord David you
two can pitch Steven against YouTube
overlord playing for the power of castle
mutt Club Oh No
YouTube is escaping hopper the battle
dog dad you saved the castle Castle mug
club from the Masters of the internet
collection Steven and YouTube overlord
each sold separately for more adventures
join my club at lauda was credited on
slash Mugler ninety-nine dollars
annually 69 for students veterans or
active military and now for barely legal
with Bill Richmond sponsored by mug Club
hi I'm half asian lawyer bill Richman
for louder with Crowder here with some
education and tips on the terms we use
in the legal world our question today
comes from Dan McGovern and that
hellhole known as East st. Louis
Illinois Dan's question is what is the
deal with the court names like Supreme
Court Circuit Court District Court and
Justice Court and who in this is in
charge of who gets to be a judge and
each one of those well Dan we're going
to split this one up into two part
and deal first with the courts
themselves most of you have heard about
a Supreme Court which is the final
appellate courts in both our federal and
state systems at the very top in the
federal system above all the courts as
the United States Supreme Court you can
end up here whether you start in a state
court or a federal court it is the true
court of last resort for judicial relief
now secondly most states also have a
Supreme Court that is the highest court
stay tuned from all barely legal with
half-asian lawyer bill Richmond but is a
contractor I went to where he works
these dudes were working they were
building a house and I saw this guy
digging this thick dude I kinda noticed
him he was he was about 5'4 about 5 feet
wide looked like a human fist no points
I'm pointing he had no points just blunt
and and he was pulling up huge chunks of
the earth just sure okay and I could I
know digging I had to bury my dog once
but I know how hard that is
and so I'm admiring the power in this
dude and I said to my buddy I go what
what is he digging man and then my buddy
who's his boss goes a pool
I was like what it's like that I can go
like that in he goes oh yeah man he'll
do it in an afternoon I was like it's
not possible he goes it's not it's not
possible but for him it is
[Music]
desire tastings
I don't know why I saying you're an M&M
it doesn't mean a whole lot enemy that
song it's everybody on the realm of
abstract almost into you would say the
corner of absurdist I don't know what
they considered this with with techno
and what provel thinks we should get any
sort of talk about it
I am very excited to have our next guest
yes I'm sure posed I'm supposed to say
I'm also supposed to pronounce it
supposed but I always get it wrong
also solace I usually get wrong as a
Canadian but I've been a fan of his for
a long time you've heard me say as far
as just stand up to the funniest and up
size ever on earth our Nick DiPaolo nor
McDonald as far as overall being one of
the funniest people alive not just
stand-up but also sketches storytelling
podcasting his show podcast is available
everywhere a fighter and the kid you've
seen him on schooled which is a spin-off
of the Goldbergs as coach Mellor
you've seen when the hangover and his
newest special complicated apes is
available on iTunes Amazon Google Play
mr. Bryan Callen thank you for being
here sir thank you for having me my
friend it's good to be here I like the
way you were dancing with just your
shoulder you were just moving your
shoulder on it was you a little bit of a
Floyd Mayweather shoulder roll it what's
up what's up I moved from the hips but
whatever right well I know you'd have
powerful it's a little-known fact I
don't know if you've I know you that
you've done wrestling in your lifetime
the Floyd Mayweather style of fighting
with the shoulder roll it only works as
your five foot two because when I tried
it the glove here did not cover my
entire dome I found out it's not the
same thing I do a little boxing I try to
do it every week and I was trying to
quote-unquote perfect the Philly shell
and I got punched in the face enough
times where I became dizzy where I was
getting foggy brain I even said to
Brendan shot was it hey I'm forgetting
things and Brendan said won't stop
sparring because you're an actor 52 and
right [ __ ] Lauren cos that's ridiculous
and then Joe gave you some DMT and all
is well with the world I assume that
that battle did that did take away my
fear of death so now right now
absolutely
you saw the clockwork elves by the way
I'm not entirely sure that what we just
described is a hard data more anecdotal
so the shoulder roll may work for you
Kalin you're just app right now you're
everywhere you have your podcast schools
I've been a huge fan of the Goldberg for
a long time I haven't watched as much of
school because I've been very busy
lately as your latest standard special I
don't wanna get you in trouble because
we've a lot of people on the show who
are obviously more centrist more
moderate and people assume that there
are right-wing neo-nazi just for
appearing on here yeah but I know and
you're special you've talked about how
kind of radicalized people have become
in many ways particularly the far left
in relation to comedy in free speech are
you worried about being drummed out of
the Corps for even talking about that
no I I just worry about telling the
truth as I see it and I and I I think
I'm worried that it's very easy it's
very easy to fall into this binary trap
that most of us fall into as human
beings we are I think probably
programmed to break into us versus then
we versus they you know those guys over
there are wrong and we're right there's
it there's a binary look at how we break
these things into teams you guys are
gonna knots will your copies you know
that you you you believe in universal
health care you must be a socialist see
here we brand these and I think
Americans have a very tough time being
both things I think it's possible this
is gonna sound radical I think it's
possible to be pro law & order' Pro cop
and also also not want innocent black
people to be shot I think it's possible
that kind of be on both of those
spectrums and I and I also think that
it's it's a good thing sometimes to use
words like I don't know maybe it depends
mm-hmm these are complicated issues and
the more I read about them the the I do
think it's important to have a
philosophical bedrock looking more into
when the wind starts blowing yes which
is why I believe in the Constitution and
why I believe in individual liberty and
why believe in all these principles that
in Maya
not only founded this country and solved
the political problem and the founding
fathers solved in many ways the
political problem aristotle couldn't do
it socrates couldn't do it no one else
could do it not that I'm not that smug
Plato he said Socrates didn't take notes
I'm gonna I'm gonna be taking minutes
and Socrates like what you should shut
the hell up Plato
well well planners Republic is basically
it's if you look at it it's a caste
system and it's it's a lot I mean Hitler
wanted them essentially you know he
wanted to art with the the architecture
of the Third Reich was based on Plato's
Republic I'm pretty sure so the founding
fathers came along I've had enormous
respect for the individual now I know
they owned a lot of human beings and
slavery was was well and good quite a
few it wasn't well I'm good with a lot
of them I mean you look at Kimber if it
was George Washington or Jefferson who
made it to the he couldn't freest slaves
while he was alive but made it so that
when he died they would join fleet but
extensively on that and there was very
aware of the contradiction in talking
about all men are created equal and I
think that's the most radical line of
political philosophy and I think we have
to remember it when when Thomas
Jefferson said that we hold these truths
to be self-evident are created equal
it's that is a that is a contract we
have all entered into because what we're
actually saying to a religious idea
which is we are all of the same moral
worth you can't prove biologically or
mathematically that we're all that we're
all equal you know I mean I might have a
Floyd Mayweather with yes sir or I
always do I talk about how LeBron James
is my chocolate avatar there's nothing
equal about us you know but but but we
all believe that at the end of the day
you don't know where I'm smart where I'm
strong where I'm courageous so best to
treat me like an individual and treat me
like I'm worth a lot that's why our
justice system is predicated on the idea
that if I kill a wretch on the street or
I kill Bill Gates technically I'm
supposed to do the same amount of time
because it's a human life right it's not
for us to judge what that that life is
worth I gotta say you talk about both
sides now people can be both everything
I'm hearing here would get you drummed
out of the core from the left saying the
founding fathers figured out a problem
ago I know about slavery but people they
will go on racism the founding fathers
were
just white males Brian's not doing
yourself favors if they're watching
though so what they do so what you do
when you do that when you say when you
stop me and you say you races white
males is now you have you have turned
those people into nouns you have you
have given them you've labeled them and
you fix them in in a category in a very
strong category meaning that now I guess
since they're straight white males in
their races that they are disqualified
and that they have zero contribution to
anything else so so that I suppose then
we could go into the fact that Mohandas
K Gandhi took baths with a young women
and that does that that that erases his
entire legacy Martin Luther King
apparently cheated and beat his wife
that erases his entire legacy well no
that was an aspect of the man right and
I think again we have to human beings
are verbs that's why I talked about my
especially being complicated age we're
complicated Apes sinners Saints
everything in between multi-layered and
multi-dimensional and full of potential
human beings are I mean look you you are
what you are now and you are also what
you could be and we forget that and we
have to treat each other that way very
money you're getting very much back into
the realm of Socrates and we've talked
about it when we do to change my mind
and talk about abortion this is a
question that I get to a Gohan say what
is a human life you're getting into this
idea of the essence of human hood the
essence of a human being this is some
pretty and can I say something I don't
want this to be a sore spot but number
one time when you were on a Joe show
good good friend you love jewelry this
is not it but I remember at one point
someone said like Brian you know you
could just reach deeper with your
stand-up because some people see your
stand-up is silly I don't see it that
way
what I'm hearing right now is the
processing of unbelievably deep nuanced
philosophical issues and then I see it
performed and stand-up in a way that
allows people other people who maybe
aren't as intelligent yourself to
process it and I've always said no I'm
watching it go no donate yourself right
we love you love you well I appreciate
that because certainly in this last set
special that's what I try to do there
there there are bad ideas out there and
one of those bad ideas socialism and and
then what I
by that as I'm by the way it doesn't
mean I'm against all government
interference but I worry that whether
you use roads Brian do you use roads do
you have running water
what are your socialist and dabei
exactly exactly so so I'm not saying we
don't need a taxation system I'm not
saying you don't need a federal
government my god you do the question is
to what degree and then rather than have
these conversations of whether or not
I'm a Republican or a Democrat or a
socialist our free market capitalist I'd
rather say to what degree do you think a
large central authority should have
control over your life I mean how much
of your money I already paid 51% 51% of
my money goes to a state and federal
government that's because you live in a
state that Donald Trump would refer to
as it pull well and and if that's the
case of I have to give so 51% of my day
is spent working for someone else I have
accepted that I get it maybe that makes
sense I don't know what the percentage
should be but I'd rather talk in those
terms but I don't know why the far left
is so they're not creative thinkers I
don't think someone like OAC
or Bernie Sanders never had a real job
by the way I don't think this is I think
this is a creative thoughtful guy I
don't nobody talks about this his his
what answer is tax the rich right oh
really
don't punish people that produce punish
people that are productive and by the
way I guess Bernie Sanders and his
philosopher Kings like Coquette Cortez I
guess they seem to know more about what
to do with that money then Apple does
Apple spends 10 billion dollars here on
research and development I think they
have a better understanding what to do
with their money to create a better
product for all of us and by the way
they might be very wealthy because they
produced a product that we all use and
by Jessie J also they're much more
charitable 2.6 percent to charity Bernie
I mean it really is right but the evil
corporation the evil pharmaceutical
companies give away more and they want
to argue it's for a tax write-off fine
but Bernie you'd buy a matcha latte
Starbucks and make sure that you have an
app that rounds down the tip to 18 look
and by the way smithkline
and whatever the laakso smell fine look
you you you there are there are issues
with Big Pharma but sure let's please
not forget that Hep C is now a curable
disease i we just we just used CRISPR
cast nine when I say we me and my
medical team here but Chris Burke ass
nine I believe to cure eight boys who
had that that disease that boy in the
bubble disease where they couldn't you
know they didn't have immune systems and
I think they they took a an HIV virus
stripped of its pathogens and reinjected
it with a certain gene that gave these
kids immune systems what what and
they're doing it with leukemia so you
know could not imagine how this baby if
you went in for plasma replacement
therapy and they accidentally gave you
that virus you're like I thought it was
my own platelets
no it's aids no but at least some boys
have immune systems if I gotta go yeah
but we are doing we're doing amazing
things with the pharmaceutical companies
may have them they may they may have
their liabilities and maybe evil in one
way or another they're saving a lot of
lives from what I have read from a very
liberal slant media I mean IIIi don't
again this is where we we kind of lose
sight of how important research and
development is and how important the
free market can be with checks and
balances but how important they can be
in moving things forward because there
is a profit motive and a profit motive
is not necessarily a bad thing it's kind
of the way human beings behave right and
that's why I worry very much that there
is a lack of creativity and creative
thinking on the left it seems to me can
i I'm trying to be fair can I ask you a
question because yeah this is a
criticism we hear lobbed at the right
very often right and I've heard it
myself and recently I think it was
Slater salon did a hit piece on Joe
Rogan they've been on Nick DiPaolo now
and of course Dennis Miller or they say
and well people conservatives can't be
funny there are no funny all comedians
are liberals and of course the industry
does lean left so it's interesting to me
that you say you don't think there's a
lot of creative thinking on the left why
then why do you think the industry and
particularly the most visible comedians
arse not just they're not kind of left
they are dyed-in-the-wool leftist do you
think that's a byproduct of the industry
and the gatekeepers
I think a lot of times you're talking
about compassionate people who are in
motion and I think that the narrative is
see it only depends on who controls the
narrative and who's able to paint the
best picture and I think that the
scientific community I think the I think
a lot of conservatives are pretty stodgy
and and not very personable maybe and a
lot of your artists have probably I'm
not I'm not a clinical psychologist but
I would imagine artists probably tend to
be able to empathize and and probably
put themselves in the place of someone
who is different than theirs I mean
that's what great novelists are able to
do right and it probably is and you need
these people and you need the left I
don't I don't buy into the fact that you
know you you don't need office opposing
forces I worry when they're not
listening to each other I worry when
we're not having idea sex I don't think
that Ocasio Cortez is a bad person I
really don't I don't think that Bernie
Sanders a bad person I happen to
fundamentally disagree with them on a
philosophical basis it doesn't mean I
want them put in jail and destroyed I
just don't agree with them and I'd love
to have a conversation to find a way to
be creative with our thinking to solve
problems that actually matter problems
like I don't want spree shooters out
there okay right I don't want I want
more research and development III
warrant may be a sensible tax law blah
blah blah I want a clean environment is
there a way we can put our heads
together the way Google or Pixar does
and and and and solve these problems
with let's just have an ideal orgy and
and that's what the founding fathers did
they sat around our very hot
July and just dueled it out with their
brains and they agreed with each other
but they just they had spirited debate
and civility then that's what was the
cup sometimes it got pretty angry but
that's because they had just switched
from tea to coffee they weren't exactly
used to it at that point
they found the tea waiting for some
things are
fighting for you to find yourself along
the lines of which you're willing to
fight right well I want to I want to
keep this going because it for people
surprised out there it's just a
pre-taped because he's in Los Angeles
and has other shows to do we're going to
keep you around for a web extended
version for those who are exclusive mug
Club members of course there's Bryan
Callen on Twitter the special is
complicated apes stay tuned we'll wrap
this up everyone else go to Mudd Club
[Music]
[Music]
join mud club at louder with CARICOM
slash mud club so we can continue to
employ sweatshop Bangladeshi children
animators
and now for barely legal with Bill
Richmond sponsored by mclubbe
Massachusetts though those oddballs call
it the Supreme Judicial Court but even
more strangely in New York calls their
highest court the Court of Appeals in
New York the Supreme Court is actually
the lowest level Court the one you see
on Law & Order
it's the Crunchwrap supreme of Courts in
New York lots going on but not really
any authority some states though have
two highest courts one for civil and one
for criminal that's probably the one
you're most familiar with Dan over there
in East st. Louis for example in Texas
and Oklahoma you'll have a Court of
Criminal Appeals and the Supreme Court
won two civil Wanda's criminal now on
our next level down we have the
intermediate appellate courts at federal
that circuit courts and other states
it's generally called a court of appeal
and below that we have trial or
specialty courts in federal court that's
called the district court in the states
that's Superior Court district court
county court county court of law family
court probate court Municipal Court
justice court there's a lot of Courts
only answer the second portion of your
question next week though it did occur
to me that since you're a white guy who
chooses to live in East st. Louis you're
probably already dead this has been
barely legal with Bill Richmond
sponsored by mug club don't forget to
stop by lotta with radish opcom to get
your goodies like this new exclusive
half-asian lawyer bill Richmond crackin
poster nifty stuff one library of the
week of course we want to take this
opportunity to thank our wonderful
sponsor Walter firearms I mean I don't
really need to do much of a pitch these
things practically sell themselves
they're cool they're firearms what else
do you need to know but if you haven't
tried a Walter firearm we just recommend
go to the range try it just try it
they've the balls to support the show
and they really are of the highest
quality out there and they're actually
gonna be at the Indianapolis Convention
Center
the NRA show April 26 through 28 so
please do pay them a visit show them
some support and of course mug club is
always available if you would like to
join what better to put in your mug then
a delicious herb alight shake I'm not
sure but I'm yeah yeah hit me up for the
details oh this is very berry the herbal
like yeah that's that's kind of a
pyramid scheme hmm it's more of a
triangle Steven is it all right well
that's just upset
certainly liquid call me today to get
your your your shake I don't I don't
even know why you're still here I do how
do you choose my side has to see if it
were short on cash we need some help
okay well we're saving up some money for
uniforms oh yeah don't buy the herbal
light no it's tasty it tastes good it's
poison it's like if you made Nestle Quik
with a placenta
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was called the surprisingly strong
Riptide drowning me just get all the way
bye everybody see my old quarter black
guy could carry this all by himself good
job I think good for you very proud of
you thank you so much Abreu and go see
the exclusive extended web interview at
mug club for those who have not yet
joined so if I can let me grab I don't
not let me grab you can leave whenever
you want yeah I mean technically let me
request if I'm gonna have a minute of
your time here I know that you hear a
lot about shado banning D monetization
there are a lot of chicken littles out
there but I do want to at least inform
you in case this channel goes away for
good as to why and as to just how easily
possible it could be for us to be gone
from YouTube tomorrow we've received
what could potentially be three hard
strikes so we have a screen shot here
for one parody video the dr. Trump music
video that we did in the span of a week
and unless we come to terms with YouTube
and the corporate overlords YouTube
rules say that three strikes get your
channel removed now I want to be clear
I'm not exactly sure in this instance if
it counts as three strikes or just one
since we use this same video three times
in a commercial break we have half-asian
alert bill Richman attempting to
establish communication with them III
don't know exactly hopefully we can work
it out I want to make clear here this is
completely a parody under the umbrella
of fair use we have some some b-roll
here we can show you what we actually
created the track from the ground up
with a project file that you guys can
see we went and we created this entire
music video from scratch this wasn't
just we can just take a karaoke trap and
by the way it has to be comfortable
enough to the original to be a parody
there are channels that subsist on
parodies alone and right here I can
actually see an example of Jimmy Fallon
did a Bernie parody Old Town Road
side-by-side with ours look they have a
30 million dollar operating budget and
ours is you mug club so I want to be
clear this might not be an exact example
of an instance here of anti conservative
bias okay but when you pair it with
disproportional targeting targeting of
the rest of our content for being quote
what they term now on the border and the
issues of notifications that have been
happening the D monetization
specifically targeting our opinions as
unpopular speech at least in Silicon
Valley
when you act when you take this the toe
tap the culmination it renders us unable
to create a show for you and if it keeps
columns where the channel will cease to
exist now what we do here is very
different as is our relationship with
with corporate censorship take for
example take for example let me give you
an example pure comedy channel out there
that only does the occasional parody
yeah you know this kind of thing would
hurt them it would suck wouldn't be
debilitating take more conservative
leading channels that maybe they've seen
some radical demonization based on a
point of view we know that happens quite
a bit but one that doesn't do comedy
it'd be hard but they can find other
ways to generate revenue let's think of
a channel that has 50 million
subscribers and they find out that the
notifications like ours are broken or
that YouTube changed an algorithm to
throttle their organic search views or
related content views it would suck not
be crippling but we experienced all of
that and we experienced it daily and
even more the rules keep changing
YouTube claims that there isn't an anti
conservative bias that they want to have
conservatives on the platform but that
they want to encourage a healthy
discussion okay I want to take that at
face value but they D monetize and
restrict the change my mind videos
genuinely here's a question to you this
isn't a victim complex we're trying to
play by the rules let me ask you
something if a conservative cannot
create a long-form unedited no profanity
civil dialogue segments like change my
mind without being punished
how can conservatives create content for
YouTube what content could possibly be
acceptable I'm trying to figure it out
and it's been a tiring week and this is
why my clip is more important ever you
can join up at lot of credit calm slash
mug Club support the show you get access
to the full daily show not broadcast on
YouTube you get this wonderful girthy
hand etched mug and the entire blaze TV
catalog in lineup and it'll allow us to
continue to create this kind of content
regardless of monetization on YouTube
and equally important it allows us to
fight legally to change these draconian
rules which hurt not just us and not
just conservatives but independent
creators and it's also what allows us to
continue to change people's minds on
YouTube by allowing us to throw caution
to the wind on monetization and
uploading anyway we don't care we don't
care if we're monetized or not because
we're monetized by you that's how we
have a parody that
better than a thirty million dollar
operating budget no offense to Jimmy
Fallon but that sucked and right now by
the way where for the next 24 hours were
offering at $20 off to anyone who joins
just enter in the promo code a lot of
credit comes flesh smuggled the promo
code I think is 2020 for everyone
number two zero for everyone or listen
to see alternative you don't join up
this show as you know it
I would we no longer be able to produce
it we've reached a crossroad unless
people join Mudd Club we can't do this
show these segments on YouTube or any
platform sure listen I could lay off the
15 people staff and crew and just talk
into a camera without any sketches any
parody satire on location videos changed
my mind or even so much is ever
addressing a controversial issue I could
do that but that's not the show that
this cruise works are to create for you
and you've made it clear that it's not
the show that you want from us and you
made it clear not just to us but to
YouTube and that's equally input that's
probably more important you've made it
clear to YouTube that this is the
content you want and it's not a
violation of any rules that's not what
we set out to do and I know people often
say we hear this a lot like well why
don't you just upload your stuff to
2-bit shoot or insert any other
streaming site of the day here and we
can and sometimes we do as a safety yeah
but it doesn't help us in any way create
content going forward that's like
telling someone who's consumer
electronics were banned from stores well
you can just you just give it away at a
flea market i we could the only way this
continues well right now we're stand on
the barrel of three potential copyright
strikes hopefully half-asian lawyer does
what half asian lawyer does but you can
help by joining up at my club we created
deliberately by the way to not be a
patreon at PayPal or GoFundMe a lot of
people have said why don't you do
patreon or you know when all of the
conservators were doing that we pointed
out it's just rattling a tin cup on
another big tank platform and they can
give you the boot and as we've seen now
they are giving many conservative voices
the shaft mug club is something that we
created to be completely independent
totally immune to the censorship and
I'll say deceptive trade practices that
you see from big tech we've partnered
with dozens of other conservative voices
so we can hopefully make it financially
viable for decades to come
I know some of you have been on the
fence and $7 a month is is not nothing I
get it but also it's been a worrisome
time for everyone involved here at this
show when you when you
wake up and find out oh crap three hard
strikes our channel could be gone within
10 days and it's particularly
accelerated in recent months after the
Oscars livestream and you know what we
all know here we've all accepted that
it's going to get worse I promise you
this you join up at mug Club you support
us i we all of us here will continue to
create content for as long as humanly
possible and continue to fight these
rules and the oppressive corporate
overlords until our coffers are
completely empty for years this channels
been up for years we've we've done it
exclusively because of you and going
forward we can't do it without you we
appreciate the support and wanted to
keep you updated we'll see you next week